hi my name is nikon vapha and today i'll
be presenting the paper average case
hardness of np and ph from worst case
fine grained assumptions
and this is joint work with legio chen
and shuichi hirohara
so we're all familiar with the p versus
np question
and but how does this relate to
cryptography
so if p equals np
we get many fast algorithms for many
hard problems
we get fast algorithms for the traveling
salesman problem
for boolean satisfiability or you know
your pick your favorite np complete
problem
but on the other hand if p equals np
then there's no cryptography
you can invert any potential one-way
function and so there's no
private key cryptography let alone
public key cryptography
okay on the other side if p does not
equal np
you know we have no worst case
polynomial time algorithm for
whatever your favorite np-complete
problem is
but what does it say about cryptography
or even about average case hardness at
all
and the answer is we don't really know
it still remains an open question
and to more
uh
precisely try to address the possible
realities we live in or possible worlds
we live in
and paulie also devised the five
possible worlds that we could live in
relating to complexity theory and
cryptography
and so one of the world is algorithmica
where p equals np or some equivalent of
this
heuristic is the world where p does not
equal np so np is hard in the worst case
yet np is easy on average
and i'll define later what i mean by
that
there's also the world pessiland in
which np is hard on average yet even
still there are no one-way functions
and you can also define worlds minicrypt
and kryptomania which are various worlds
in which cryptography exists
and so one of the main open central
questions in complexity theory and also
cryptography
is to answer the question of which world
do we live in
currently we could live in any of these
five possible worlds as far as we know
okay so
one chain of implications is immediate
so if there's publicly cryptography
there are one-way functions
and if there are one-way functions then
np must be hard on average
and if np is hard on average it must be
true
that p does not equal np
the other direction though remains
unknown
so we don't know if p not equaling np
for example
means if np is hard on average
and furthermore if we did have the
second yellow arrow that's that has a
question mark
if that were true
then that means p doesn't equal np if
and only if np is hard on average
which means that heuristica cannot exist
because np cannot be simultaneously easy
on average
yet hard in the worst case if this
yellow implication were to hold
so any of these yellow implications
corresponds to eliminating a possible
world that we live in
unfortunately there are many barriers in
the way of trying to prove these yellow
implications and i'm not going to get
into all of them but just for this you
know heuristic pestland implication
we have a black box barrier
we have a hardness amplification and
possibility barrier
and we have a relativization barrier and
so any proof that shows that np is hard
on average if p doesn't equal np
has to simultaneously overcome all of
these possible barriers
okay so let's give a little bit of
background and complexity just to
solidify notation
so p will be the usual polynomial time
np will be non-deterministic polynomial
time
up
standing for unambiguous polynomial time
will have the same definition as np
except that all inputs have at most one
witness
so in np
yes instances are allowed to have
arbitrarily many witnesses as long as
it's at least one and no instances have
zero witnesses
but for up
yes instances have to have exactly one
witness
and no instances have to have exactly
zero witnesses
we can define sigma 2p and pi2p in the
standard way so sigma 2p is the class np
where you're also given an oracle to np
and pi2p is a set of all complements of
those
languages and we can define the
polynomial hierarchy to be in some sense
the limit of
np to the np to the np and so on to be
the polynomial hierarchy
now i'll define some average case
complexity notions so by average p
i'm going to refer to the set of all
length pairs of languages l
and distributions d
for which there's an algorithm that is
always correct
and moreover the expected run time
over inputs x as distributed to
distribution d is polynomial
and one thing i really want to emphasize
here is that the distribution that we're
considering when i say expected
polynomial time is over inputs according
to some distribution d
so it's not the case that the polynomial
the expected polynomial time is with
respect to internal randomness but
rather it's over the inputs x
and
great
and before i go on i should mention that
there are also other notions of average
p which are one-sided error and
two-sided error and in fact almost
everything i say today is also going to
apply to a one-sided error notion
of average p but just for simplicity i'm
going to phrase it as average p
and we can also define a distributional
curly c or curly c some complexity class
to be the set of all languages l or l's
in this complexity class along with
distributions d
where d is polynomial
timestampable and once again for this
talk it'll turn out that d will either
be the uniform distribution
or it will be the unary distribution
where all the math is just on one string
say like one to the n
or will be some sort of hybrid of these
two distributions in some sense
but just for simplicity i'm going to
phrase it as distributional c
so recently hirohara has made some
wonderful progress
towards potentially eliminating
heuristica
as a possible world we live in where
heuristic as a reminder is a world in
which np is hard on average yet
easy in the sorry excuse me np is hard
in the worst case yet easy on average
so we showed explicitly that up as we
defined on the previous slide
where all what all strings have at most
one witness
if u p is hard if it requires two to the
o of n over log n time
or more than that
then this means that np must be hard on
average or in other words that
distributional np is not contained in
average p
moreover you showed the same thing for
the polynomial hierarchy in some sense
and also for np instead of up
but where now we showed that np does not
have p computable average case
polynomial time algorithms whereby p
computable i just mean that given an
input you can efficiently estimate the
runtime of your heuristic algorithm on
this input
without having to run it which could
potentially take exponential time
and this
this result it turns out
also had some barriers like we discussed
it had to overcome a black box barrier
a hardness amplification and possibility
barrier
yet it wasn't clear if it had to go
through a relativization barrier
and you know one can ask can you do
better than this two to the o of n over
log n
uh worst case complexity assumption
in other words can you maybe go to two
to the little o of n over log n
and it turns out that this question
would have to overcome a new
relativization barrier as found by
hirohara and nanoshima
so if you were to try to improve these
results you'd have to go over a new
relativization barrier
and one thing i want to emphasize
is that these results just fall short
of the exponential time hypothesis
as a very quick recap the exponential
time hypothesis
is an assumption that says
you know a three c and f formula with m
variables
requires time two to the omega m
to solve
so you know requires exponential
in m the number of variables uh time to
solve
and so if you write that out in terms of
the length of the full instance
you know n is the length of the full
instance and m is the number of
variables this corresponds to an
assumption like 2 to the little o of n
over log n as we saw here that has a
relativization barrier that's new right
at that running time
so you can ask you know is there any way
to get average case hardness from eth
and not these stronger worst case
complexity assumptions
you know can we do better
and in fact even scth is too weak to
imply the non-trivial average case
hardness from those
theorem statements directly
so you can ask what is the weakest worst
case complexity assumption
that gives you non-trivial average case
hardness or some interesting statement
about average case hardness
from a hopefully weaker worst case
complexity assumption
and the answer is that you can get away
with
average case hardness or non-trivial
average case hardness from eth and even
much weaker in some sense worst case
assumptions just to spell it out a
little bit more concretely
we show that if u p requires time 2 to
the o of root n log n or requires more
time than that
so here we it's not o of n over log n
but rather 2 to the over root n log n
then
we get that the non-deterministic linear
time
can't be solved on average in
quasi-linear time
so here we have a much more fine-grained
sort of average case hardness results
but it's still non-trivial
we still get some non-trivial average
case hardness
from a weaker much weaker worst case
complexity assumption
our second result
is sort of the extension of this to the
polynomial hierarchy
and there's something i really want to
stress here
which is that in paleozoic phrase is an
open question
can we get average case hardness of np
from average case hardness of the
polynomial hierarchy as an open question
and it remains open today
and you can even ask a simpler question
of can you get average case hardness of
sigma k plus 1p
or
rather can you get average case hardness
of sigma kp
from average case hardness of sigma k
plus 1p
and here we show that you can get
average case hardness of sigma 2p
from average case hardness of sigma kp
for any k
and in fact not only average case
hardness but from worst case hardness of
sigma kp for any k
we get average case hardness of sigma 2p
so this sort of results gives some sort
of partial answer to impoverished's open
question
as well as
uh relates goes all the way to worst
case complexity assumptions giving you
your average case hardness in the
polynomial hierarchy
and lastly just to relate it to eth
directly
eth is an assumption it says that a
non-deterministic linear time can't be
solved on average in time n to the one
plus epsilon for some epsilon
where furthermore we require that the
run times effectively can be estimated
in also n to the one plus epsilon time
another way to interpret our results is
through fine-grained complexity
so one can ask whether fine-grained
cryptography exists
and by finding great cryptography i mean
cryptography where adversaries are given
slightly more time than honest parties
you know you can ask about fine-grained
one-way functions which have been
explored
and in fact it's been known that
fine-grained average case hardness of
zero k clique and also aura of case some
imply the existence of fine-grained
publicly crypto
so in the fine grounds we're a
fine-grained world we have a
transformation from average case
hardness of these particular problems
to public key cryptography
and you know similarly can we try to
eliminate a fine-grained version of
heuristica
and what do i mean by fine-grained
heuristica
well i'll give one definition of the
five grained possible five worlds where
here when i'm talking about cryptography
i really mean adversaries that run in
quasi-linear time and n
so n times poly logarithmic and n
time
and with this definition you can define
algorithmic heuristica etc in a similar
way
and as before we have trivial
implications upwards
we have unknown implications downwards
each of which corresponds to eliminating
a possible fine grained five world
and our work can be viewed
as an implication saying if u p
has some worst case complexity
assumption that it requires more than
time two to the o of root n log n
then
we get that non-deterministic linear
time is hard on average in the sense
that it can't be solved in quasi-linear
time on average
so before diving into the technical
pieces let me give some meta complexity
background that will be useful
so we will be using the notion of
time-bounded columnar growth complexity
so let some string x be have length n
we'll define the time bounded common
growth complexity of x this kt of x
to be the length of the shortest program
pi
or if you were to just run pi on its own
it would output x in time at most t
so you can think of k t of x to be a
compression quantity how much can you
compress x
such that the time to decompress to get
you back to x
takes time at most t that's one way to
interpret this quantity
and just some quick facts
first sufficiently large values of t
uh kt of x is going to be at most n plus
plus big o of one because there's a
program
that's just you know prints the
following string
x
and the length of that program will be n
plus a little bit just for the
for the you know wrap around
another fact is that this bound for most
strings this bound is actually almost
tight
and this fact comes just from the fact
that there can't be too many programs
uh
that are that are short just by counting
and you can also have a generalization
of this
where your program pi
now also has access to an oracle a when
you try to decompress to get you back to
x
one notion that we'll use centrally
from here on out is the notion of time
bounded computational depth
so here s is going to be less than t
and we can define the computational
depth on x
with time balance s and t
to be the difference of ks of x and kt
of x
so informally if you want to have an
intuitive understanding
you can think of it as how much more
can you compress the string x
if your decompression time bound goes
from s up to t
how much more can you squeeze in your
compression
let's give a super quick overview of the
hirohara break
breakthrough
framework
so a simpler version of some of his main
theorems is that if np is not in time 2
to the o of n over log n
then sigma 2p is going to be hard on
average
so let's prove this by the
contrapositive
so suppose that sigma 2p is going to be
easy on average
it turns out and this is his main result
that this implies that for any language
in np
and for sufficiently large t
we have a worst case or we have an
algorithm solving l
and on this input x
the runtime is going to be 2 to the
computational depth of x
with time bounds t and p of t for some
polynomial p of t
and n times some polynomial in t as well
overhead
okay
great
but what do we know about this quantity
this computational depth that's in the
exponent here
and when is it small
you know can we choose a
a nice value of t
for which this computational depth is
small
and
if so then
we have a fast algorithm that solves l
which is great
but how do we
find such a t
the point is we'll argue that for some
value of t it'll be small and we're
going to try many of the t in parallel
and see whichever one it gives us the
results and as soon as one of them does
we finish and output that
and how do we argue that for some value
of t this computational depth is small
first i'll define this iterated
polynomial with itself
so remember p of t is a polynomial
and so p raised to the i of t so
iterated with itself i times is just
going to be p of p of p p of t where you
do that i times
and now consider the following sum
so let's just look at the left hand side
so we're summing here over tau terms
where tau is a parameter i haven't
set yet
and what we're summing is the
computational depth
first you know the first term is going
to be the computational depth of time t
and p of t
of x
then we sum the computational depth of p
of t and p of p of t
on x
and so on up to tau terms all the way up
and the key point is that the sum indeed
telescopes
you know the second and the third term
here are going to cancel
and
the fourth and the fifth will cancel as
well and all the terms will cancel
leaving just the first and the last
terms which you can interpret as a
computational depth itself
and the point is that since this is just
the difference of two kt complexities
this is going to be at most n plus big o
of one
so just to recap this big sum is going
to be at most n plus big o of one
and so by an averaging argument one of
these terms must be at most n over tau
plus big o of one
okay great so what does this give us in
terms of a run time for our algorithm
so say say our polynomial p of t
is a polynomial t to the c
so c is just some constant let's say
bigger than one
and so if we start off with our initial
time t
being polynomial and n
and if you unfold the runtime we get
from the main lemma from hirohara
this turns out to be t to the 2 to the n
over tau where this n over tau
corresponds to the computational depth
of this optimally chosen t
and then times your you know your poly t
overhead and that worst case that's
going to be
p raised iterated with itself tau times
on our initial t
and this gives you 2 to the n over tau
times n
to the o of c to the tau
because we iterate this polynomial with
itself tau times
and just to recap you know this is our
run time for an algorithm that we solve
l on any input now x
and so what's the last thing we have to
do we just have to balance
to balance these terms you end up
setting tau to be proportional to log in
at log of n
and for sufficiently small constant
epsilon the runtime becomes 2 to the o
of n over log n
and this is the main sketch of uh the
work of your horrors skipping many many
steps
but the point is now we've solved the
problem l and np in time two to the o of
n over log n as desired
great
so what if we wanted to improve these
results if we wanted to go beyond two to
the o of n over log n
how can we do better
the main point is that
this iterated polynomial with itself if
you do it tau times
this growth in tau is extremely fast
it's in some sense doubly exponential in
tau
and that means you can't really do
better than setting tau to be
logarithmic and n
otherwise it'll be too big
so for the moment let's suspend reality
and assume that the polynomial p of t is
just linear in t instead of a larger
degree polynomial
so to be concrete let's say p of t
equals c times t
then iterated with itself tau times
this is c to the tau times t
and the point is that this is singly
exponential in tau not doubly
exponential
and if you do the math and if you
balance
what we're going to get is 2 to the n
over tau
sorry
if you get 2 to the n over tau
times c to the o of tau
times polynomial on n
and to balance this you're going to set
t to be root n proportional to root n
which gives you in the exponent 2 to the
o of or gives you 2 to the o of root n
overall
and this is much much less than two to
the o of n over log n
so this is a win
and in fact
you know we can't quite get p of t to be
linear but if you get p of t to be
quasi-linear so t times poly logarithmic
and t
then if you just run the same argument
back you'll get 2 to the o of root n log
n so we get an extra root log n factor
in the exponent
and this is what we end up getting at
the end of the day
so the question is how do we get p of t
to grow slowly
the point is that the main bottleneck
and i'm not going to get into the
details here just for time's sake but
the main bottleneck and proving
hirohara's main lama
to get small pft
is derandomization so to get small pft
we need very efficient derandomization
and moreover the
the results used in the in the hirohara
lemma is that if np is easy on average
then we have a prg
of log n c length that's secure against
t time algorithms
but that the prg itself is computable in
poly t time
so in other words we have a discrepancy
between the security which is only
against t time algorithms but itself
it's computable only in poly of t time
is there any way to refine this so that
the runtime of the prg is closer to the
runtime of the algorithms we want to
fool
and this is one of our main technical
contributions we get extremely efficient
de-randomization from fine-grained
average case easiness of np
so explicitly if we have this average
case easiness of non-deterministic
linear time
if it's in quasi-linear average time
then we have a prg that has log m state
length
it constantly fools all t time
and m bit advice distinguishers
and moreover this prg
is computable in time t times polynomial
in m
so think of t here as much larger than m
and if that's the case
we're fooling t time distinguishers
and our computation time is t times
polynomial on m where poly and m is much
less than t
so the overhead here
in the computation of the prg
is very little
so we have extremely efficient low
overhead
way to full t time computation
but at the duke we do have a cost of log
of t bits of advice in computing this
prg
and so let me try to give a super high
level sketch of how we construct such a
prg
and for the moment i'm going to imagine
a simpler version where we construct a
hitting set generator from average case
easiness
and i'm not going to define hitting set
generator exactly but it's effectively a
prg
where
you only try to de-randomize one-sided
error algorithms
so you try to hit some set of possible
random strings that your algorithm will
accept very very roughly
and the key tool we're going to use is
an extractor from shaltiellen-umans
which says roughly that
if you have
some avoider d
which point one avoids
su some function scu of x and random
string
then you can convert that
distinguisher or this this avoider and
use it in a black box way
to reconstruct x
for some for the appropriately chosen
advice alpha
so in other words there's always going
to be an you know if you have an avoider
d
there's going to be some advice alpha
such that if you reconstruct with advice
alpha and with avoider d you can output
x
so why is this useful
well the cooler corollary is that if we
can find some x that is large kt
complexity
much much bigger than the length of the
advice alpha
then
this s u of x is going to be a hitting
set generator
and why is that true
it's true because if not in other words
if we had some avoider
for scu of x
then you can plug in that avoider into
your reconstruction algorithm
and with some small advice alpha
you can package that all together
to be some compressed short program
that's efficient
that outputs x
and so that means that the kt of x is
going to be small because we've just
evidenced a program that runs quickly
that outputs x
so we've reduced all of this to just the
question of whether we can efficiently
find some x that is large kt of x
and once again the very very short
version of how we do that
is a mixture of the time hierarchy
theorem
and efficient pcps
probabilistically checkable proofs
so super super roughly
x will end up being the truth table
of some accepting oracle for a pcp
of a language that we get out of
applying the time hierarchy theorem
and it turns out that
if we did have a short efficient program
for this truth table
then using our average case easiness
assumption
you can convert that ultimately into a
deterministic program
that solves the language l
but that contradicts the fact that l is
hard
unconditionally because l
is given to us by the time hierarchy
theorem
and so that's a very rough sketch of the
proof
and that's the end of the technical
portion of the talk
okay just to summarize and some open
questions
first of all
as before
metacomplexity remains a really powerful
tool to overcome barriers that release
words that relate worst case and average
case complexity
so our theorem statements didn't have
anything to do with meta-complexity
itself
yet as a tool
ended up being very useful
to have metacomplexity to relate
worst-case and average case complexity
another thing is that if we
go to the world of fine grained
complexity
this allows us to give a refined
connection a more strengthened and
refined connection between worst case
and average case complexity
and in this light maybe you know
fine-grained cryptography is a much more
achievable goal
and lastly unsurprisingly
pseudorandomness can be very useful
could be very powerful
and just to finish with some open
questions
is there any barrier to improving this
two to the o of root n log n that we get
uh
you know maybe some barrier comes up in
going beyond that you know can we do
better can we do not remains open
and similarly can we try to exclude
fine-grained pestyland or have some
evidence
to exclude fine-grained pestyland
instead of just a fine-grained
heuristica
all right thanks so much